hi there steve kaufman here and i'm back
indoors
because it's sometimes windy outside and
the sun is very
bright and so it's a bit less reliable
so i'm back indoors
i've hooked up my microphone to my
computer where i'm recording and using
audacity
rather than relying on the recording of
the iphone i hope this produces better
sound quality i want to talk today and
maybe in the next couple of videos
about talking and about mistakes
because all of us when we learn a
language we eventually we want to speak
uh if we're in a situation where we're
able to use whatever limited
amount of the language we have you know
we'll typically do so certainly when i
was in japan
as soon as i could even say anything to
anyone i would try to do so
uh in vancouver if i come across an
iranian speaker i'll try and say
something in
in persian so that's the main goal but
you all know if you follow my videos
that i'm very much a proponent of
input-based learning listening and
reading and the reason for that is
simply that when we're in a conversation
and we don't understand what people are
saying and we don't have any words
it's it's painful so you know i
have started speaking more in persian
and in arabic and i've gone through
periods where i had a lot of online
sessions
and online sessions with tutors are
great
actually it's a phenomenal capability
that we have today and
i want to salute italki which has a wide
range
of teachers in a tremendous range of
languages
so i can connect with people for example
in iran uh
from different cities so i'm getting to
know different cities in iran and they
talk about
where they live and the food they eat
and and all the while i'm speaking and
in order to speak well you do have to
speak a lot there's no
getting around it and uh as you continue
with your input
based activities at least that's my
strategy as i listen more and i read
more and i acquire more words and i
understand more then
more and more i want to speak and as i
go to speak i
i discovered that a lot of the words
that i've learned i can't remember them
when i go to speak
but the more i speak the better i get at
speaking
so we do have to speak a lot
and and i even think that in order to
speak a language
really well and not be in danger of
losing it
you have to possibly spend time in the
country where the language is spoken you
need to speak so much
that that you can eventually
get a sufficient hold on that language
that it won't it won't
be frittered away by by lack of use
because i know that when i go back into
my greek many stories or
uh you know many stories in romanian
that there's a lot of words that i'm
going to have to learn
again because i've forgotten them which
isn't a problem to me
because i have them there i can go back
to them when i learn them again i will
eventually
know them better however speaking
is a phenomenal way of learning the
language
now some people suggest you should speak
from day one
i've never quite understood that because
day one you know nothing
so even if you engage in a conversation
all you're doing is is is well you can't
say anything
uh the person you're speaking to has to
explain everything
that they're saying and my experience
has been that when i'm in a conversation
and especially if i don't understand
very much and then the tutor tells me
this is
the word for such and such i can't
remember it it's impossible to remember
i find that it's much more useful for me
to hear it
than to read it and hear it again and
read it again
and gradually allow the brain to get
used to the language
that way but when you start speaking
whenever that may be
early in your learning or later in your
learning listening is a big part of
speaking
paying attention to what the speaker and
especially if it's a native speaker
is saying so it's still very much an
input-based activity
and the less of the language you already
have in you
the more of an input-based activity the
speaking is
but it still can be quite painful
uh if you are with people and you simply
don't understand
anything i guess there are people who
believe in this
speak from day one and who practice it i
don't know how that works
uh i have been you know uh had
tutor engagements at an early stage of
learning a language and i find it
painful i can't wait till the session is
over
because i can't really understand what
they're saying and i can't find any
words
at least if i have learned the words
through my input
activities and can't remember them at
least i have a hope of eventually
remembering them but if i have no idea
what these words are and then they are
given to me in the class
there's no way i can remember them so of
course one of the things that i do
in my uh sessions with tutors is i ask
them
the tutors to produce a
text file with a list of 10 or 15 or
however many words they can
ideally they do it during the lesson so
it doesn't become an extra 10
15 minutes work for them all the words
can't be all but of the words that i
used incorrectly or couldn't remember or
wasn't able to use
or phrases if they can create a list of
these
10 15 20 and in an ideal scenario
record them then send them to me then i
import these as lessons into link and
and you know i can then review these
over and over again i can review
uh you know these reports from a lesson
two months prior and gradually
get to know these words and start to use
them
but so the talking it's important to
talk
i think it's exciting now that i've
spoken to a couple of tutors in iran
recently
one lives in espahan one lives by the
caspian sea
see there again she gave me we must have
mentioned the name of the city where she
lives
three or four times i haven't seen the
it written out yet
la john maybe i can't remember it you
know
we have to recognize that it's not just
because i'm old you can't remember stuff
like that
uh and so but at any rate have a tutor
from isfahan a tutor from up there near
the caspian sea
a tutor from tehran the tutor from up
north
she is originally from la restan which
is somewhere else in iran
so you're talking to people you're
getting an understanding of the country
of what is going on
in that country of the geography of the
country you're using words
you know ideally you're using words that
you've learned you're picking up a few
words
you're practicing the art of speaking
because to speak well you have to
practice
speaking uh you can't just all of a
sudden stop
you know you've been listening and
reading now and engaging you know with
all the good things that i do at link
and you just go there and start speaking
it doesn't work that way
however my experience has been that you
can activate it pretty quickly
and very often i will study a language
with the purpose of going to the country
and i did that in romania i did that for
greek i did it with czech
with russian ukrainian and when you're
there and you're able to
you're sort of immersed in it and and
working hard to try to
keep up with the conversation that there
is a sort of a white heat there that
pro you know pushes you forward to that
next level
but but you have to have a certain
minimum in order to take advantage of
that
say going to the country and similarly
before you can engage with a tutor in a
meaningful way in my opinion
you have to have invested in
uh you know listening and reading it and
then these uh
sessions where you're talking they are
become an opportunity then for you to go
back to your listening and reading
and pay attention to things that that
you missed so
it's important to talk i don't think it
matters when you talk
some people like to talk early i don't
think there's such a thing as talking
from day one
because someone has to give you
something so here's how we say hello how
are you
then you say hello how are you it has to
start with listening it doesn't start
with speaking
and so the only question is how much
listening
and reading do you want to do before you
start speaking
and that will depend on people's
inclinations that'll depend on their
situation
on their needs but at whatever point you
start speaking
a big part of the speaking is still
listening and paying attention
and getting the language into you even
as you practice the art of speaking
and get better at retrieving the words
and phrases that you have
so that's all i wanted to say about
speaking
and i'm going to leave a couple of
videos you might look at that are sort
of relevant to this